so
keep it
[Music]
so
uh
okay sometimes it stalls on you
it's soft you get here you guys often
bouncing around you can't get it okay
then you're gonna take your elbow off at
the last second but you're gonna move it
take the other leg
i like to use the palm hill to do the
trick
up
okay okay so it's still your union
reconciliations you see so
as i move over here this is free space
this is free space and it's as much a
free space as this
you see it's still in space
okay so just because i'm in tight
doesn't mean i'm not doing jiu-jitsu i
am i moved into the free space okay and
then he has all
his wages on the front leg you see so
that's his young leg
and that's his input yet leg so i pick
it up his life doesn't weigh anything
all his weight was on the other leg
so free space
pick it up okay now i have that rotating
cross
that you have all the time so his center
is where it is i don't want to kick his
center up
and i don't want to move his center
backwards that takes fast
right where his center is that's what i
push it's very light i didn't move it
okay it moved around his lips moved
around it
so same thing home freeze race yin
that then moves in place
it's not a muscly move i'm not muscling
him not muscling
it's all yin and yang reconciliation
boom pump
right okay then free space
okay rotating cross go